how're you guys doing
I'm doing excellent first of all let me
start by saying how much I enjoyed the
movie and there is a surprising amount
of subtext in this thing too much now
we're done talking about the film for a
quick second we're gonna play get to
know your small foot cast member okay
okay what TV show would you love to
guest spot on I would like to play one
of the one of the Dead and Game of
Thrones and I'd like to be I'd like to
be a gangster on ozark okay I think well
you're screwed on Game of Thrones cuz
they've wrapped but that's possibility
do you ever think I'd have actually done
it it might have been it yeah are you
telling me you never know they're gonna
kill me do you have a favorite sci-fi or
fantasy films ooh uh Dark Crystal Blade
Runner what what film scourge was a kid
start crystal it original terrified
notes I was here I was like 14 round a
guy called Steven Fletcher's house
because he had an older brother who had
it on VHS and was it weird that it was
Steven and Steven justice the whole
thing was horrific
I hated it I loved the new um is there
anything that you collect my mom's
giving me a knife every Christmas sort
of sort of collect knives yeah I have
quite a few soccer team what I would
call football team shirts true official
jerseys yeah I've been lucky enough to
meet players and anytime I've met one of
I signed them and I was my son's just
got in soccer I was showing him the
other day and I was like oh this is
working into quite a nice collection it
was nice yeah do you own any moon
or TV show props oh not of our own mic
yep I've kept a sword of my own I'm
trying to give it anything else that I
have this not like some I don't know
this isn't me directly but I was
involved in its purchase my best friend
Ben who's the exact producer of the TV
show I do has you do a TV show of parts
of yes as part of David Letterman's the
bridge that were behind Letterman for
the 25 year he's turned it into a into a
side table and it's really great that's
amazing yeah yeah I'm also you should
let me know the address so I can borrow
it because he probably doesn't need it
anymore
well it uses in be is the way to Egypt
he just someone just got out of a skip
for it they just they just trashed the
entire they were gonna for out the desk
until someone went but you probably hate
me we should I may do this crazy
yeah um is there have you watched any TV
show all the way through more than once
the West Wing yeah founded three sons
Aaron Sorkin oh and the bake-off sure
you mean I don't know oh no no I don't
think so I already got a rap but a
background photo on your phone it's the
last question cool on that note
congratulations on the movie thanks man
I really mean it
you